comedy people don't even be cannot even
begin to understand the human tragedy
that is comedy it's unbelievable most
shows are there like pranks this jackass
like what does color cameras around I
like to do this term I don't care where
you work I don't care if you work in a
cancer ward of sick children
there is nothing sadder than what this
is I don't care if every day you have to
walk into a room and tell a bunch of
parents it's his last warning go on in
there and kiss him
that is much more uplifting yeah then
dealing with the fear oh yeah
zombies that walk the earth in hell it's
like we just saw this great play the
ferryman in New York City and man I wish
I had that quote from a Greek mythology
or something where the guy goes and
there's just these thousand souls Hades
won't even take him on the river across
the like owl or whatever uh-huh there's
these thousand souls they just walked
the earth
undead looking waiting for the ferryman
and I'm like oh [ __ ] I know them all
yeah I know those people I got them in
my phone and you gotta be nice but no
it's okay just I can't show up cuz of
this or that you can't just say like
you're an absolute sociopathic maniac
I'm not saying that I am [ __ ] you
know I like anything that should be
respected or whatever I'm saying if you
have a show tonight I walk through show
to a for people that right and I said
we're not doing this right now cuz then
they looked at me like I was insane
right no see it doesn't matter who you
are it matters that you're a human being
that deserves human respect
Josh Quinn and for whatever reason the
minute you say you do stand-up people
are just like no it's okay you'll come
you just stand up in my bathroom to my
you know I was in it right you can't
come do stand-up in my bathroom Cody in
the top